hello I'm Donna Friesen we're all
finding ways to cope in this new reality
getting accustomed to living a
physically distant existence but there's
nothing normal about this silence and
emptiness where there's usually hustle
and bustle it's disconcerting social
distancing is not what cities are
designed for and it's not what most
humans are wired for we've shut down so
much to keep coab in nineteen from
spreading because this is a physical
health crisis but there's something
deeper going on inside us
it's sowing the seeds of a major mental
health crisis whether it's grief over a
loved one's death fear of getting sick
anxiety over losing your job and not
being able to pay the bills
psychological distress is widespread and
the stresses have multiplied especially
for those dealing with mental illness
before the pandemic hit abigail Beeman
explores the impact dealing with a
pandemic is an extra challenge for
Christina Dell korpal the montreal woman
has general anxiety disorder because
we're all going through this joint with
traumatic experience it's definitely
easier for me to get set off and like to
start panicking so that's why I have to
be like extra vigilant and pay attention
to my emotions but after the year she's
had that's not easy struggles with
infertility her father had a stroke and
then Dell corpo planned to start her own
design and digital marketing business
excited for a new challenge she quit her
job in January right before the world
shut down there's some of these were
like just terrified that you know
someone I love will get sick or maybe
we're gonna lose our condo or you know I
won't be able to find a job after all of
this is over because there's so many
other Canadians that are like without
jobs Dell corpo knows she's not alone
Health Canada tells global news eleven
million Canadians will show high levels
of stress in family and work settings
and two million will show signs of
traumatic stress projections based in
part on the aftermath of SARS where more
than 40% of Canadians suffered from
increased stress levels but by the time
this Panda
is over numbers could climb even higher
separate polling by both if Sousa and
Angus Reid show half of Canadians feel
their mental health has already worsened
we know that it's not it's not just a
secondary wave it's actually happening
right now our service volume has doubled
for young people who are reaching out
for support an increase of about 50%
more calls than we were receiving this
time last year two examples from
organizations on the front lines
typically what we would see a social
isolation increased concerns around
mental health or symptoms that they're
experiencing and what we're seeing with
kovat is an increase in all of those
things that they've been somehow
amplified it's also meant a change in
how mental health workers provide that
desperately needed support
Toronto's Gerstein Center was forced to
close their short-term beds and park
their mobile crisis van now they're
focused on calls and wellness check
outreach but it's not the same as soon
as we can get back to face to face the
better these staff take calls for 12
hours a day and in a pandemic that can
feel endless the mental health of
frontline workers is also a concern
there's still this lingering concern of
going into work and working in close
contact with people and potentially
contacting iris Courtney Jackson just
launched the frontlines a publication on
medium encouraging other workers to
share their stories she's a mental
health case manager at a residential
care facility in Ontario burnout is a
real problem
so is isolation with many health care
workers self isolating from loved ones
within their own homes I mean working in
the mental health fields you expect to
deal with stress and change it's it's
part of the job but the difference is
that right now I'm working with people
who have a limited understanding of the
situation they feel powerless to the
situation but I myself also feel that
way so in a country that saw long wait
times for mental health services before
the pandemic struck what's being done to
help health care is a prevention
responsibilities and a number of
provinces have stepped up with new
programs and millions in new funding
help is available Alberta is leading the
way after a government survey found 74
percent of Albertans feel their mental
health has been hit by kovat 19 the 53
million dollar additional investment
that we're announcing today is more than
all of the other provinces but what's
being done at the federal level the
Prime Minister keeps promising all kinds
of help but the fact is there's no clear
number on new mental health dollars
coming from Ottawa as the funding is
tied to other things this month the
Prime Minister committed two hundred and
forty million dollars to boost access to
virtual care including mental health and
25 million of that is going to the new
wellness together portal connecting
Canadians with free help including phone
text and video counseling there will be
more to do and we know that this the
secondary pandemic if you will is just
as in many ways as in my fact I would
say it's just as urgent as this one in
its first three weeks more than a
hundred and fifty thousand Canadians
used the portal help is offered via a
number of partner agencies not
government employees after eight
thousand volunteers answered a call from
Kids Help Phone now the service known
for helping kids is responsible for all
the texts that come through the portal
anybody that texts whether they're a
youth or they're an adult will text 24/7
and reach one of our trained volunteer
crisis responders and those are
volunteers that go through a rigorous
training process and they're overseen in
real time by paid professional staff but
the site does ask you to provide your
name and email the agency overseeing it
says there is help available without
registering and the data is only visible
to the person submitting it designed to
be like a Fitbit people are able to see
their progress so that's the Peter
Cornish says they're working on a way to
make registration optional as they brace
for increased demand over the next few
months he says as it develops peer
mentor
will become more important so that
everyone can support each other better
which is why we came up with the name
wellness together Canada Cristina del
corpo is managing pretty well these days
and she wants to help others too so
she's been blogging you didn't always
feel this stressed out this bad and it's
gonna pass and just keep that in mind
and keep pushing for it and if you
really need help reach out to someone
the battlecry of this pandemic has been
we're all in this together or put
another way you're not alone
[Music]